traveling is more than just going on a
trip
sometimes our adventures help us to
rediscover a part of our identity or get
to know ourselves better than when we
first packed our suitcase let's go to
Ghana my name is Kyle Cody juice ODG
Vanessa can be or accident Jones this
great big story was made possible by the
Ghana Tourism Authority
we're from Orange County California and
last year we sold our home and traveled
around the world with our family to 36
countries there's such an immense amount
of history there that we had to
experience it for ourselves the Ascend
Monceau slave market is located in
central Ghana and it was a place where
enslaved people were auctioned off and
sold one of your ancestors it was an
incredible piece of history it was sad
but it also gave us a profound
appreciation that we are here because of
that struggle is the Bible people food
and I'm just very glad that our kids got
to express the African part of the world
I'm an Applebees artist and someone
who's very passionate about making a
social change for Africa and this
Passport I was born in London but I also
grew up in garland my music always
intended to teach people about one from
which is
Tianna Fest is a festival that's running
annually in Accra to me it was very
important that we had a physical ground
that you know anybody who loves afro
beats can come to and enjoy themselves
music has kind of become a weapon for us
to come together and help connect the
dashboards you know Ghana has the purest
people the purest vibe the best food
I've had to make on a special country I
[Music]
was born and raised in Edinburgh in
Scotland but my dad is from Ghana I
think of me since I was three so going
there literally just feels like going
home if you were there to go and get
back to your roots it's great for that
but it's also great for just like
kicking back and relaxing I have found
my ultimate favorite hotel in the whole
entire world in Ghana and it's called
lumen and it's in AK scene which is
about six and a half hours away from
Accra my favourite gallery in Ghana is
gallery in 1957 and I loved that space
there Ghana is so special in so many
ways this place is just so vibrant I was
born and raised in Maryland and I've
been living in Thailand for the past ten
months I decided to go to Ghana because
as an African American what I do know is
many Africans who were forced into
slavery actually came from this part of
the continent
Almina slave dungeon is a very slow
growing experience and it's an
experience that anyone from the Diaspora
should go and feel for themselves we
also got a chance to visit Willie
waterfall Willie waterfall is the
tallest waterfall in Ghana we spent time
in the Accra metropolitan area it had
its own interesting vibe and culture
the biggest highlight in Ghana was its
people they were warm and hospitable
I would suggest anyone whether you're
from the Diaspora or not to go
experience for yourself hey I'm Kyle
Kobe and I'm a youtuber blogger I'm gonn
yin and German I live in the UK the
highlight for me visit in Ghana has to
be the food the family and the culture
my favorite places to go is chop bars a
chopper is a restaurant that is normally
outside and you just go there you order
or then take Ghanaian food the truck
bars I like to go to always located in
tomorrow
the beach I love to visit when I'm in
Ghana is al-abadi Beach because it's
just so local and it's so nice over
there the ocean is so beautiful one blue
majority of my family are from Ghana is
just such a big part of me and just
something I can't wait to experience
with my children it's just such an
amazing country and I'm so happy to be
from there it's important to travel in
general just to expand your mind expand
your thoughts and be inspired it's just
such an amazing thing to be able to just
go to different countries it's gross
different people's culture
travel is important because it gives an
individual and a chance to experience
the world from a different perspective
you get to meet new people you get to
learn about life sometimes you even find
yourself it just widens your horizons
whitens your mind and your knowledge but
also seeing how other people live and do
things means that you can learn from
them
[Applause]
you
[Music]